eu vou falar de stress
se o fábio vai falar de felicidades ea
deborah valor de gratidão se é depois
nós vamos ouvir sobre meditação estresse
praticamente estaria na contramão de
tudo isso mas vamos ver se é bem assim
em 1967 quando o brasil estava naquele
regime da ditadura ea vida cotidiana era
cheia de perigos de ameaças de
incertezas
gilberto gil fez uma canção na contramão
ele disse vou fazer a louvação do que
deve ser louvado meu povo preste atenção
repare se eu estou errado
louvando o que bem merece deixando o
ruim de lado
eu quero falar do stress bom não do
estresse que nós estamos acostumados a
ouvir e ao qual nos referimos quando nós
estamos em desgaste quando estamos
sobrecarregados quando estamos é
incomodado os preocupados na incerteza
na depressão eu quero falar do estresse
bom aquele que constrói as coisas boas
da vida inclusive a alegria o sorriso ea
felicidade porque nós temos um conceito
aliás nós temos uma série de conceitos
que não nós precisaríamos repensar nós
estaríamos revisar esses conceitos
o ser humano é um ser conceitual ou seja
aquilo que ele coloca na cabeça como um
conceito geralmente determina o
comportamento
então um evento como este está tentando
trazer novos conceitos novas
perspectivas novas visões da importância
da gratidão da importância da meditação
trans e do sorriso da importância da
esperança aliás gilberto gil vai dizer
assim louvo a vida que é um bem maior
louvo a esperança da gente que a vida
vai ser melhor pois quem espera sempre
alcança três vezes salve a esperança é
de camorra mantém 11 no livro meus
demônios
no último capítulo em que ele chama
crueldade do mundo e ele mostra neste
último capítulo que realmente a
crueldade ou mal sempre vence o bem em
toda a história da humanidade e o único
elemento que o ser humano tem para fazer
uma certa resistência a essa tendência
que já é natural é esperança pois bem
stress tal qual nós conhecemos faz parte
de um desses conceitos que nós
precisaríamos revisar por exemplo o
tempo passa rápido
não é verdade de maneira nenhuma
somente através da dor é que realmente
se aprende não é verdade
o sol nasce a cada manhã sou nunca nasci
mas nós colocamos esse conceito na nossa
mente
alguns acreditam que exista uma verdade
única e absoluta
outro conceito que desorienta muito mais
do que orienta a nossa vida a nossa vida
é feita muito mais de estresse bom do
que diz traz mau
se fizermos um real levantamento de
todas as coisas que acontecem no nosso
cotidiano débora
nós vamos chegar ao final do dia
realmente precisando agradecer ao stress
bom de cada dia
nós todos estamos aqui porque fizemos
uma trajetória de estresse a não ser que
tenha alguém aqui que diga se não tudo
me caiu do céu
tudo foi uma
beleza eu ganhei todas as possibilidades
não precisei lutar para adquirir
absolutamente nada
bom esse se ele fez isto não passou no
vestibular que é o grande stress é pelo
qual o gargalo pelo qual nós temos que
passar se quisermos ter uma profissão e
nenhum sucesso na vida a gente alcança
sem lutar bastante nisso quer dizer que
a vida seja um sofrimento nem que a vida
seja só stress
existem dois conceitos de stress
um é o bom estresse do qual eu quero
falar aqui um pouquinho e outro do mal
stress denominou se ao bom estresse eu
estresse mas a palavra não pegou e
denominou se ao mau stress aquele
estresse que provoca doença o desgaste a
qual nós sempre nos referimos e se
denominou se diz trés do prefixo grego
diz que quer dizer distúrbio de expulsão
por tanto estresse mal e se todo mundo
conhece e eu não vou falar dele porque
eu fiz a opção do gilberto gil louvar o
que bem merece deixando o ruim de lado
não para assumir uma posição otimista
ingênua não é para colocar uma visão que
talvez seja concordante com que cada um
de vocês está esperando e que os colegas
aqui vão falar sobre a probabilidade a
possibilidade de stress contribuir para
a felicidade que tem uma coisa não se
consegue felicidade sem um bom stress
estresse é tão bom que ele mobiliza o
nosso corpo para as coisas boas muitas
vezes a gente o vê escrito stress
provoca problemas ao seu coração causa
do distúrbio cardiovasculares é verdade
quem lê isto vai pensar que deve evitar
o estresse
a imagem em baixo quando se vai lendo a
matéria tem assim para ele
tarô stress ande com run faça musculação
faça uma atividade esportiva danse a
dança circular faça coisas boas na vida
ora não é possível dançar e não agitar
todos os hormônios de estresse do
organismo tem um conselho que é sempre
dado evite elevador subir as escadas
se quiser subir até o nono andar onde eu
moro que vai acontecer é que minha
freqüência cardíaca vai aumentar minha
pressão arterial também vai se alterar
os meus hormônios de estresse adrenalina
noradrenalina e cortisol vão ser
descarregados na corrente sanguínea em
uma quantidade muito grande
a minha rede neural os
neurotransmissores vão ficar
extremamente ativados e elevar a
descarga de 80 em quatro diferentes
neurotransmissores para que eu posso
chegar lá ao 9º andar
ora sem stress eu não posso subir a
escada
então se esse é o conselho que eu devo
subir as escadas para poder evitar
doenças cardiovasculares logo o estresse
faz bem ao meu coração e eu preciso dele
para poder evitar as doenças
cardiovasculares
aí nós estamos falando então do estresse
bom é aquele que nos dá o prazer de
viver
se nós queremos ser felizes nós
precisamos dele
caso contrário ninguém poderia fazer
absolutamente nada porque tudo está
vinculado ao bom estresse
acontece que este vício de pensar o
estresse como sendo mal já fez raízes no
nosso pensamento e é muito difícil
quando você recomenda para alguém olha
se estresse bem a cada
dia nós vamos de parar imediatamente com
uma resistência
eu não tenho outra sugestão a fazer para
ninguém e muito menos para minha vida
senão essa estressar bem gostosamente se
nós praticamos um bom estresse de cada
dia é muito fácil viver feliz em são
paulo
é muito fácil viver feliz em são paulo
porque aí nós vamos está ativando o
organismo ii a mente porque os dois
estão relacionados como a gente bem sabe
na medida certa para fazermos bem todas
as coisas
sucesso na vida e na profissão no amor
só é possível através de um bom estresse
imagine alguém que diz assim ar hoje à
noite tive uma belíssima transa não me
estressei nada estou apaixonado e não
dos absolutamente nada estressado
faz parte da natureza que quem estiver
apaixonado tenha uma descarga tão grande
de hormônios do bom estresse na corrente
sanguínea
ative o corpo tanto que ele não dorme à
noite e no outro dia ele está disposto
feliz fita' lizado então tenha a
vitalidade por causa do stress
se você não quer ter bons tracey de cada
dia você também não vai conseguir ser
feliz
eu tenho um paciente que me disse assim
referindo se a uma pessoa que por quem
estava apaixonado já tinha um
relacionamento há muitos anos
ela é a minha maior angústia mas também
o grande amor da minha vida é um
tremendo estresse não pergunte a ele se
ele quer desistir desse stress
de maneira nenhuma aí vem o resiliente
porque o resiliente é aquele que melhor
sabe lidar com o stress
nós temos visto muito falar se nas
mídias sobre resiliência resiliente é
aquele indivíduo que não foge da
adversidade mas se coloca diante dele
portanto é aquele que melhor sabe lidar
com o stress algumas características do
resiliente que são muito interessantes
que eu gostaria de colocar pra vocês
rapidamente que ao mesmo tempo sugerem
de como podemos lidar com o stress
quotidiano
dissemos antes que ele não foge mas ele
enfrenta o stress a fuga leva à
depressão
a fuga levou pânico a fuga leva a uma
série de síndromes o resiliente
geralmente não têm doenças físicas nem
psicológicas
se tiver ele sabe lidar muito bem com
essas doenças
ele não adota uma postura otimista
ingênuo am
mas ele tem um profundo senso de
realidade
quando nós enfrentamos o estresse com
esse profundo senso de realidade é o
caráter ameaçador do stress se altera o
resiliente dá sentido à adversidade ou
seja o estresse um grande estresse no
qual ele está inserido se coloca na vida
dele ganha um sentido e um sentido
geralmente não é negativo
nietzsche e disse que
quem sabe por que pode suportar todo e
quase todo como viver
portanto dar sentido ao stress na nossa
vida e um sentido positivo é um caminho
para a resiliência o resiliente opto por
dignidade ou seja ele quer ser digno
dentro da adversidade
então ele precisa com isso ressignificar
o stress e não entendo como negativo
para a vida
ele foca no bem que existe dentro do mal
todos nós conhecemos aquele símbolo do
yang no símbolo do yang
o mal está no centro do bem e o bem no
centro do mal
o resiliente dentro da universidade
ele foca no bem que está e que existe
dentro dele resiliente tem uma
capacidade de transcendência muito forte
ele se dedica à transcendência ele não
toma os fatos conforme eles são
colocados portanto ele transcende aquele
estado e cria um estado de excelência
mesmo em se tratando de uma diversidade
mesmo se tratando de um grande stress
ele não tem inclinação para o desespero
e aí está uma das características do
resiliente que nos mostra como ele lida
bem com estresse que geralmente nós nos
estressamos quando estamos estressados
nós nos desesperamos ficamos irritados e
nervosos agressivos resiliente não fazer
isso porque ele não tem uma inclinação
para o desespero
ele ergue se acima do destino externo ou
seja das condições que são colocadas
resiliente
ele tem uma fé que o alimenta e ilumina
nós estamos vivendo um período em que
está sendo possível se falar de fé ea fé
ea espiritualidade
não estou falando de religião estou
falando de espiritualidade a fé como um
dispositivo para viver bem
apesar das condições estressantes em que
estamos inseridos
portanto resiliente alguém que
transforma o estresse ruim em estresse
bom se nós tentarmos fazer isso se nós
mudarmos este conceito e entendermos que
os hormônios de estresse que circulam
dentro do nosso corpo do hipotálamo
hipófise glândula supra renal e todos os
outros sistemas do nosso podem
contribuir para uma vida de plenitude de
prazer intensa e feliz
nós vamos conseguir transcender a
característica negativa do stress
transcender do mal para o bem
eu gostaria de ir pra finalizar mostrar
como o estresse pode ser bom
daniel barenboim o grande maestro
resolveu fazer isso o desafio estresse
desafio tão intimamente ligados à
filarmônica de berlim ele resolveu
convocar os seus músicos a tocarem tico
tico no fubá
vejam que gostoso pode ser o stress e
quanta satisfação ele pode proporcionar
quem quer que ouça esta música para
executar o tico-tico no fubá
é preciso stress ninguém pode executá lo
de uma forma relaxada
não é preciso muito stress é preciso que
muita adrenalina correndo nas veias
é preciso que muita dopamina seja
descarregada que é o que vai dar o
prazer de ouvir essa música e executá la
sem dopamina e sem muita dopamina
circulando no corpo
nós não vamos sentir prazer é preciso
muita ou citou sim uma outra substância
que dá uma satisfação imensa do contato
o sorriso vem porque a ocitocina é
descarregada no nosso organismo
a alegria e vejam ao final a alegria do
público ao ter ouvido tico tico no fubá
com daniel barenboim por gentileza
a gente andou estresse na vida de cada
um no cotidiano de cada um
o restante é tico tico no fubá